[Musica]
buonasera
oggi vi racconterò una parte anzi un
grande riassunto della mia avventura
anche perché ho 37 anni non li dimostro
lo so perché
ho iniziato a gareggiare
quando ne avevo 9 quindi non ci
basterebbe tutto il pomeriggio per
raccontarla allora riassumiamo vi
chiederete come la storia di uno
sciatore sia collegata a un autore di
fama internazionale come pirandello e la
tematica realtà finzione
beh voglio partire da una parola
una parola che noi sportivi
odiamo con la quale tutti abbiamo che
fare prima o poi nella nostra carriera
chi più chi meno in base alla fortuna
però difficilmente qualcuno di noi
riesce a schivarla sempre
io faccio lo slalomista pensavo di
essere bravo a schivare
schivo paletti da quando sono nato però
a schivare questa parola sono stato un
disastro
bene questa parola è stop
è una parola semplice e banale che
trasmette una cosa dolore
dolore determinato soprattutto da un
infortunio
che sembra polarizzati azzerare tutti i
tuoi progetti
ma in realtà
è l'opposto
si tratta proprio di una finzione
linguistica
questo fermarsi questo interrompere il
proprio percorso il proprio obiettivo il
proprio viaggio verso l'obiettivo verso
il nostro sogno ti spinge anzi ti
obbliga a cercare un'altra strada
appunto la realtà
il dualismo realtà attenzione che
rappresenta la tematica odierna è quanto
mai centrato su questo punto
perché lo stop diventa un'opportunità di
crescita non è più uno stop ma
un'opportunità di crescita
purtroppo la strada alternativa
non è facile da trovare
a volte è nascosta non si vede al primo
sguardo
bisogna rimboccarsi le maniche
cercare e ancora cercare questa strada
però c'è sempre ed ha una caratteristica
fondamentale
è più lunga e più ripida della
precedente
di conseguenza il viaggio è diverso da
quello che ci aspettavamo
forse il traguardo non sarà lo stesso
forse la strada sarà molto lunga ancora
di più di quello che ci aspettavamo ma
quando arriverete sulla cima sarete più
forti sarete migliori sarete più esperti
avrete vissuto situazioni inaspettate
provato emozioni nuove e visto paesaggi
diversi
questo percorso alternativo può
diventare un'opportunità di crescita
e un'avventura indimenticabile
come vi dicevo iniziato a lasciare
quando avevo 4 anni
e la mia storia piuttosto comune un
ragazzino
dell'appennino reggiano
che aveva un sogno
sull'appennino reggiano dovete sapere
che siamo sfortunati rispetto alle alpi
non abbiamo le stesse piste ma proprio
per quello
abbiamo forse un po più di passione un
po più di amore verso questo sport verso
lo sci io ho iniziato a fare grazie a
mio padre
fabbro di professione maestro di sci
come hobby e ho seguito l'iter classico
15 club
prima garette provinciali poi regionali
poi essendo bravino nazionali e ho avuto
tanta fortuna nella mia vita soprattutto
quella di avere una famiglia che ha
fatto tanti sacrifici tantissimi
sacrifici per permettermi di inseguire
il mio sogno
diventare uno sciatore professionista
ovviamente loro non sono bastati perché
ho avuto anche la fortuna nella mia cara
emilia di avere vicino a casa di avere
fior fior di professionisti che mi hanno
guidato
supportato e fatto crescere
costantemente
ma probabilmente le cose devono avere il
proprio equilibrio e quindi ho avuto
anche molta sfortuna
con i famosi stop che non sono riuscito
a schivare gli infortuni
a 15 anni ero
arrivato ad essere uno degli sciatori
dei ragazzini più promettenti a livello
nazionale e internazionale
mi dovetti fermare per due anni per un
problema di schiena
con mio padre ho girato tutto il nord
italia tutti i professori tutti i
luminari conosciuti
e stata dura perchè non non ci credevo
più gli ormai avevo perso le speranze
invece mio padre mi ha spinto a provare
un'ultima dottoressa
perché la sentenza era smettere di share
mi ha spinto a cercare
di fare quest ultima visita da un autore
da una dottoressa di bologna che faceva
rpg io gli risposi di sì ma gli rispose
anche papà è l'ultima non ce la faccio
più
e bene l'ultima fu quella buona mi mise
in piedi mi rimise in piedi e un anno e
mezzo dopo ero in nazionale giovanile
trovai in qualche modo quella strada
nascosta di cui vi parlavo prima ci misi
più tempo del previsto assolutamente ma
alla fine la trovai
per esprimere a pieno il mio potenziale
però ci misi tre anni i primi due mi
serviranno a recuperare il gap fisico
che avevo con i miei compagni di squadra
perché tutti gli anni col premier la
schiena avevano compromesso la mia
preparazione
quel periodo di stop comunque va
cambiato le cose
io ho dovuto oro dovuto ho dovuto
cambiare strada
compensati con la tecnica ma il gap
comunque andava colmato e quindi ogni
anno un passo avanti
coppa italia poi coppa europa
nello sci scalare le posizioni non è una
cosa veloce e immediata perché bisogna
fare punti per migliorare il numero di
partenza che noi chiamiamo pettorale per
poter poi
giocarsi le posizioni che contano il
podio partendo col pettorale 70 non si
può puntare alle prime posizioni
esordì in coppa del mondo il mio 22esimo
compleanno
due anni dopo fece il primo podio tre
anni dopo fece la prima vittoria
e poi ci fu il grande evento
il grande sogno le olimpiadi di
vancouver
bene le ho vinte
le ho vinte perché sono arrivato pronto
perché la strada
che mi ha fatto perdere tempo sia
cercarla che a percorrerla ha fatto sì
che io fossi in grado di farlo in fin
dei conti il tempo non era stato affatto
perso anzi era quello che mi aveva
rinforzato
arrivato all'apice con la medaglia d'oro
al collo
devo dire che le premesse per la seconda
parte della mia carriera erano molto
buone
invece dopo ancora un anno ottimo in cui
vinsi e fece diversi podi ne passarono 3
in cui raccolse poco molto meno delle
aspettative
ma risolvendo alcuni problemi fisici e
di materiale luci nuovamente a tornare
al top
finalmente allora della raccolta era
arrivata ogni gara faceva un podio un
risultato nei primi 5 6
ero nel mio momento migliore della mia
carriera
avevo 30 anni
non avevo punti deboli ero forte in
tutte le piste e in tutte le nevi solo
non so se seguite forse qualcuno conosce
questi nomi sono più famosi che il mio
molto famosi che il mio
ircer e kristoffersen erano più forti di
me ma in certe piste
sapevo che potevo essere io il migliore
e una di queste piste era kitzbuhel una
pista magica
antica difficilissima unica
ebbene quel giorno avevo il pettorale
numero 1
era una cascata di ghiaccio ea me piace
il ghiaccio
in partenza io sapevo di poter vincere
ero pronto ero di nuovo pronto a vincere
e volevo vincere ma l'epilogo fu diverso
entra in una porta tracciato in modo
pericoloso
troppo velocemente
avevamo visto tutti i ricognizione che
bisognava frenare io frenay ma non
abbastanza e mi ruppi il ginocchio i
miei compagni miei avversari poi dopo di
me
frenarono molto di più ma ormai il mio
ginocchio era andato e la cavia ero
stato io
e devo dire che nonostante la mia laurea
ad honorem in fisioterapia
me l'hanno consegnata dopo che ho
passato tutta la vita sul tanto della
mia vita sulle attiva la fisioterapista
ho sbagliato i tempi
di recupero pensavo di farcela in 6 8
mesi avevo già in mente la la strada
diversa da fare per queste otto mesi
e invece fu diverso dovete sapere che un
atleta professionista si allena a 12
mesi all'anno e fa una settimana di
riposo completo
ma bastano 15 20 giorni di stop
per cambiare le carte in tavola e
perdere oltre 50 per cento dello stato
di forma acquisito a quel punto ci vuole
un piano b e 1 c per poi ritrovarsi a
fare quello di perché la programmazione
cambia continuamente
per adattarsi ad ogni imprevisto e gli
imprevisti sono sono sempre lì anche il
più piccolo miei preparatori luca e
roberto che si occupano da moltissimi
anni della mia condizione fisica e
mentale hanno fatto un lavoro enorme per
permettermi
e per farmi affrontare ogni imprevisto
nel modo migliore
lavorando
professionalmente e con grande
esperienza
si può anche rimediare ai piccoli
imprevisti soprattutto con l'esperienza
ma un ginocchio diverso un ginocchio ci
vuole almeno un anno per recuperare
completamente lo stato di forma
precedente io ce ne mesi 2
ricordo che nel tragitto verso
l'ospedale
pensai da becky fuel a milano pensai che
fu l ci vediamo l'anno prossimo l'anno
prossimo avrò la mia rivincita
nel mentre persi punteggi dovetti
ricominciare daccapo perché l'ho finito
partire con il pettorale numero 70 in
coppa del mondo come vi dicevo prima è
dura col 70 inizia a far eco pur off e
coppa italia
ritornare a far legare con i diciottenni
dovete ri costruire mattone dopo mattone
non solo la mia forte forma fisica ma
anche tutto il punteggio necessario per
partire con un pettorale decente
quando gareggiavo con i diciottenni devo
dire che io da
da grandicello e non è stato facile però
nella situazione sono riuscito nella
difficoltà della situazione sono
riuscito ad apprezzare molto i giovani a
imparare da loro e loro imparare da me
perché a stare con i ragazzi si rimane
giovani e anche la mia sciata la mia
tecnica ne ha giovato
parlando di rivincita per avere una
parte della rivincita ci misi quattro
anni non 14
decisamente più del previsto ed era il
2020 sempre lì sempre lì a chi fuel
nel mondo di oggi la società gira
e diciamo che parla sempre del tutto e
subito
sempre meno persone sono disponibili a
impegnarsi nel tempo per raggiungere un
obiettivo
cercano scorciatoie
stratagemmi la mia vita da sportivo
invece mi ha insegnato che le
scorciatoie sono pura finzione e che il
successo vuole raggiunto passo dopo
passo
ma nella realtà tutte le difficoltà e
l'impegno volta la ricerca della
soluzione agli imprevisti mi hanno
consentito di crescere come uomo ogni
volta che ero costretto a ripartire da
zero anche se nella realtà non ripartiva
da zero
in qualche modo
mi trovavo magicamente migliore più
forte
migliorato
quando mi chiedevano in questi ultimi
due o tre anni perché fosse ancora
lottare in coppa del mondo
quando era anni è tempo che non facevo
più podi che non avevo certe
soddisfazioni
io rispondevo sempre che la mia
rivincita non era completa che mancava
qualcosa non era finita
paradossalmente ogni anno l'età avanza
per tutti era sempre più difficile
raggiungere questa rivincita
c'era solo la speranza di farlo ma ho
continuato a lavorare
ogni giorno sperando
di poterla completare prima o poi
quel giorno è arrivato quest'anno
dove ho concluso la mia stagione di
nuovo tra i migliori al mondo e migliore
tra gli italiani
centrando il podio a wengen come atleta
più vecchio della storia isla uno
speciale
un anno il 2022
che mi ha visto di nuovo al cancelletto
di partenza delle olimpiadi
giocandomi la vittoria fino all'ultima
porta
sfiorando la medaglia per 26 centesimi
questa è la realtà che diventa finzione
perché quei pochi centesimi in cui ci
giochiamo tutto
rappresentano la punta dell'iceberg
mentre la vita
rappresenta la parte sommersa
dell'iceberg
ma la verità è anche un'altra
quest'anno nella mitica kit che come vi
raccontavo mi ha tolto tanto in tutta la
mia vita in tutta la mia carriera
una carriera lunga 28 anni
sono arrivato a tre porte dalla vittoria
a 37 anni sono arrivato a tre porte da
chiudere il cerchio di tutta la mia
carriera
ma ho sbagliato
ho sbagliato vicino al traguardo
buttando via un'impresa
è stata una grande delusione
ho gli incubi che la notte mi svegliavo
ripensando questo addosso ho sbagliato
in un dosso mi svegliavo facevo il dosso
lo sbaglia come risvegliato facevo dosso
e loro sbagliavo
però
questa delusione
ha fatto sì che l'anno prossimo sarò
ancora lì a cercare di crescere di
migliorare
perché le scorciatoie
sono finzione e la realtà è fatta anche
di grandi delusioni
ma la vita di grandi sogni
[Applauso]